il y a des produits boudés par les
Français le fois gras 20 ouais
contrairement au pâté comme tu as dit le
pâté pire que 2,1 % ex et c'est l'écart
entre les deux qui montre bien qu'on
remplace l'un par
l'autre donc on rempace le pâté par le
poid gras par le pâé même sur le
chocolat même sur le chocolat on a vu
que les chocolats de Noël hein sont en
baisse alors que ce qu'on appelle la
conféterie de chocolat c'estàd les
chocolats normaux de tous les jours eux
sont encore en hausse donc ça veut dire
qu'on remplace l'un par l'autre parce
que ce qui est cher et ben on arbitre et
on laisse de côté
ouais le champagne ouais comme tu as dit
tout à l'heure moin 20 ouais exact tu es
fort je vais t'interroger je crois que
je connais les chiffres et le mousseux
il il perd que en gros c'est zéro on est
dans l'épaisseur du trit pour faire ça
exactement ouais il paraît que c'est le
prcoo qui mais tu es pas là je vais le
donner
moi son en train de l'interroger ouais
c'était marqué 0,4 je crois que c'est ce
que j'avais dit dans l'épaisseur du
trait ouais e
oh
redescend je Mo aussi je conis c'est
quand Mme un peu mon sujet mon sujet le
saon fumé non non mais je laisse mes
camarades combien le saon fumé fumé il
perd aux alentours de 10 et la truite
fait plus 4 la truite fait plus 4 mais
j'ai jamais mangé des truites moi la
truite fumée c'est la même chose
pu je peux
dire j'ai un problème avec le poisson en
ce pouroi pourquoi je sais pas j'ai un
problème et quoi c'est quoi le problème
blage je vouis t'en parler oui vas-y non
je te jure c'est vrai en fait non mais
je te jure j'ai un problème avant je
j'ai un problème avec l'odeur du poisson
j'adore le poisson c'est hyper bon ta
gueule non mais c'est non mais j'adore
les
poissonadore le poisson j'adore le
poisson mais même le saumon fumé ça
commence à me gêner qu'est-ce qu'il faut
que je fasse alors le saumon fumé ce qui
peut gêner c'est quand il est mal fumé
quand c'est des
es de fumaison des additifs et non pas
quand c'est fumé au bois de parfis il y
a du saumon qui est fumé mais très fumé
et il est la teté du saumon parce que il
paraît que c'est les saumons en fait qui
on la plus salteté qui sont les mieux
parce qu'il y a moins de colorant tout
ça alors non alors plus non manière très
très sérieuse vous avez trois critères
de qualité pour le saumon est-ce qu'il a
été congelé ou pas parce que souvent il
est congelé sur les lieu de production
paril est DC il fait toujours fumer les
autres poissons l'aiment
pas non mais non non mais et donc ouais
et donc donc premier sujet c'est est-ce
qu'il est congelé ou pas le deuxième
sujet c'est est-ce qu'il est fumé au
bois de être ou est-ce qu'on a mis
dessus une espèce de de mixture voilà
qui est fumé et c'est des additifs et
c'est quand même pas très très bon et pu
ensuite il y a est-ce que il est sous ce
qu'on appelle un signe de qualité est-ce
que c'est bio est-ce que c'est la belle
rouge et là alors ça va vous coûter très
cher ça va en gros de 25 30 € le kil à
60 et il y a une vraie proportionnalité
du prix et de la qualité sur sur la
couleur du saumon parce que c'est vrai
que moi moi par exemple moi je comme les
enfants moi je prends toujours le saumon
qui a la plus belle couleur et en fait
parfois il y a des saumons ils ont des T
mon sont rassera vraiment c'est blanc tu
vois vraiment et il paraît que c'est les
meilleurs j'arrive pas à les manger
j'arrive pas à les manger on dirait les
vieilles couilles qu'on a a PL ça fait
longtemps que j' n'i pas vu des voilà
mais plus sérieusement pass à la
maison non plus sérieusement le saumon
ce que l'on fume c'est du saumon
d'élevage très très majoritairement ça
veut dire qu'on on décide de la
nourriture qu'on lui donne et dans la
nourriture il y a de la pigmentation ce
qui donne le orange c'est du B carotaine
c'est la même chose pour nous d'ailleurs
quand on vare bronzer on mange de la
carotte B ah ouais le saumon
sa et les fesses roses aussi et le
saumon non mais c'est vrai sérieusement
le saumon sauvage hyper gentil avec les
f roses manges beaucoup de
carot car un mec qui hyper tigant avec
les fesses roses ah tu manges beaucoup
de carottes hyper gentil F rouge pense
qu' m et donc ou et le saumon sauvage
celui que l'on pêche dans le Pacifique
est un saumon qui est plus clair parce
que il a pas été complémenté dans sa
nourriture est meilleur il a moins
de propr exc plus ch il y en a beaucoup
moins
donc jambon ou la dinde et C moins les
roses et mieux all y a moins de de
nitrite alors ça c'est pour le jambon
c'est pour le jambon quand vous ach
quand vous achetez du jambon sans
nitrite il est gris ouais il est
dégulasse c'est l'impression qu'on a
l'impression qu'on en a mais est
meilleur pour
la oui parce qu'il est moins appétissant
parce qu'on nous a conditionné à ce que
le cochon est rose le cochon est rose
donc le jambon est
rose non le jambon est gris quand il est
cuit quand il est cuit le jambon devient
gris et ouais et ouais donc le jambon
gris c'est le meilleur mais c'est
meilleur pour la santé parce qu' y a pas
de nitrite dedans si si sérieuxux et
c'est pour ça aujourd'hui vous avez
plein de marques qui font du sang
nitrite sera de toute façon interdit de
faire de la charitie avec des nitrit Ros
en fait ben oui mais sauf que quand il
est vivant il est souvent plutôt rose il
est rose clair mais le Cochonou oui le
ralouf ou c'est ça c'est exactement ça
leou
alors que quand il est cuit il devient
gris il devient voilà oui le ralouf on
parle on parle bien de ce même animal
avec la queue comme
ça non et moi j'ai des fois je suis un
peu parce que des fois il y a le vous
avez envie de vous confier ouais ouais
ça des fois le saumon il est fumé et
genre ça sent comme du lar parce que je
sent du lar fumé ça m'énerve c'est la r
de fumaison c'est la r de fumaison et
non mais vraiment quand vous avez un
produit qui sent le fumer avant de
sentir quoi que ce soit d'autre c'est
que ça a été mal dosé tout simplement
bien sûr bien évidemment bien évidemment
donc le le la fumaison c'est quelque
chose qui se reproduit très bien
chimiquement et la tentation c'est de
masquer un goût qui n'existe pas ou qui
n'est pas très bon par de l'arome de
fumée et si alors dernière question
voilà pour no téléspectateurs donc en
foie gras on prend quoi en saum on prend
quoi et en alcool on prend quoi qui est
le moins cher alors moins cher et
qualité prix en foie gras le bloc de
foie gras
c'est des fois gras qui sont mélangés
entre eux qui sont moulés qui sont cuits
c'est accessible mais c'est pas le
meilleur fois gras vous avez ce qu'on
appelle le foig gras entier à l'autre
bout ça c'est très cher ça vaut entre 80
et 100 € des trucs accessibl c'est bien
pour ça que j' arrivé ma recommandation
parce que ça existe c'est du bloc avec
morceaux l'avantage c'est que c'est
c'est quand même fait comme du bloc donc
ça coûte moins cher mais il y a 30 ou 50
% de morceau dedans donc vous avez cette
espèce de mâche qu'il y a quand vous
achetez FO grand entier et qu'il n'y a
pas quand vous achetez du bloc qui fait
plus pâ dans l'esprit voilà et donc le
bon compromis c'est le bloc avec morceau
c'est un peu plus cher que le bloc mais
c'est beaucoup moins cher que le foie
gras
voilà sur le saumon moi je recommande
clairement prenez des truites prenez de
la TR la TR fum je vous mets à l'aveugle
je vous mets à l'aveugle du saumon fumé
de la truite fumée je dis
pas pas personne VO je dis que allez il
y en a beaucoup qui vont pas le voir
faut aller chercher est-ce qu'on peut le
faire maintenant et franchement la
fruite avec un peu de citron un peu de
crème diff je vais vous dire la vérité
j'aimerais qu'on aille tout de suite
acheter de la truite fumée et du saumon
fumé avec du citron
et voilà on peut le faire tout de
suiteon peut le faire tout de suite
l'avantage qu'il a je vous le dis
franchement c'est la frite elle est
française voilà et si on veut être un
peu si on veut être un peu patrioque
dans No achat parce que la majorité des
truites sont faites dans les Landes et
dans les prén bien sûr bien sûr le
saumon il vient vient de Norvège et il
vient d'Écosse voilà moi j'ai rien
contre les Norvégiens rien contre les
Écossais mais il faut savoir si on veut
quand on nous interroge dans les
sondages est-ce que vous voulez
consommer français on nous dit oui c'est
l'occasion de le
faire suédois de français exactement
voilà c'est ça voilà voilà par ex vous
customisez la truite vous allez aimer he
et pour le champagne pour le champagne
il faut accepter l'idée qu'une partie de
la valeur perçue réside dans l'étiquette
donc si vous nêtes pas capable de ne pas
mettre V
ut MRE cont si vous êtes capable pas le
dire ce que c'est vous mettez un bon
crément à moitié prix ils y veront que
du feu voilà non mais ça dépend est-ce
que vous mettez la bouteille sur la
table ou pas c'est juste ça parce que
dans le champagne le goût est aussi
conditionné par ce que l'on
voit rest avec nous parceon va parler de
la ville de Bordeaux ça pour un
Toulousain je pense que je suis le plus
légitime et compétent tu viens de
toulouseou je vraiment Dolé même du
gerse derrière j'adore le Gers j'adore
voilà je connais très bien est-ce qu'il
peut juste redonner l'appli pour les
promos juste ça bal ça sécrit BO o n a l
ou TR pour tiens des tiens des mais il y
en a que deux il y en a que deux comme
ça et après vous avez les applis de
toutes les enseignes Carrefour Lecler
Auchan ils ont tous leur enseignes mais
dessus vous n'aurez que les prospectus
de leur enseignes à eux évidemment
Lecler ne met pas celle d' ça te dérange
si on se retrouve dans un instant vas-y
vas-y j'ai un train à
21h15as où frère je vais je rentre à
reen alors il faut qu'il aille là frère
tu vas rrer ah e tu as 1 heure non tu
veux y aller vas-y vas-y non non non
c'est bon on a le temps on encore un
quart d'heure j'ai encore un quart
d'heure c'est vraiou ta voiture vient
chercher dans un quart d'heure ouais bon
bah très bien alors tu restes r grand
plaisir